every single star wars film has started
off with one of these where there's a
possibility that rogue one might end up
being the first ever to ditch the iconic
opening cross in a recent interview with
e w Lucasfilm Prez Kathleen Kennedy
revealed that the team has yet to make a
decision on how to introduce audiences
to the upcoming standalone film quote
the crawl and some of those elements
live so specifically within the saga
films that we are having a lot of
discussion about what will define the
Star Wars stories separate and apart
from the saga films so we're right in
the middle of talking about them no
matter the decision it will ultimately
set the tone for all future standalone
projects including the highly
anticipated han solo project coming in
2018 the premise of rogue one can
actually be found in the opening crawl
of the original Star Wars you know those
rebel spies who managed to steal secret
plans to the Empire's ultimate weapon
the Death Star unfortunately we'll have
to wait until December to see this story
come to life on the big screen so the
question remains should Lucasfilm
reserve the yellow crawl for just the
Star Wars saga films or should be
standalone stories also get the iconic
treatment let me know in the comments
below and for more movie and video game
news keep it gamespot
you